استضيف اليوم اكثر من يمكنه ان يتحدث عن
ملف اوكرانيا من وجهه نظر امريكي على كوكب
الارض انه ستيفن الذي قضى اكثر من ربع قرن
في الخارجيه الامريكيه ركز فيها على
علاقات بلاده مع الاتحاد السوفيات السابق
واوروبا وقضايا الحد من التسلح والامن شغل
منصب نائب مساعد وزير الخارجيه في مكتب
الشؤون الخارجيه في مكتب الشؤون الاوروبيه
والاوروبيه الاسيويه مكلفه بملف روسيا
واوكرانيا بين 2000 و 2004 بعد ان شغل
منصب سفير الولايات المتحده في اوكرانيا
من عام
1998 حتى عام 2000 قبل ذلك كان مساعد خاصا
للرئيس بالكلام والمدير الاول لملفات
روسيا واوكرانيا واوراسيا في مجلس الامن
القومي
احييكم اينما كنتم من العربيه وهذا البلد
والاخر
[موسيقى]
مره ثانيه اهلا بكم يعتقد خبراء ان تهاونا
زعماء غربيين في مقدمتهم الرئيس الامريكي
الاسبق بارك اوباما في سياستهم خارجيه هي
التي رسخت ميزان قوه جديد بدا من سوريا
وامتد حتى اصبحت اوكرانيا ضحيته الاساسيه
بدا ذلك عندما تهاون البيت الابيض مع قصف
ضواحي دمشق بالاسلحه الكيماويه في اغسطس
عام 2013
في اسرائيل بعد انشغل منصب رئيس الوزراء
من عام 2009 الى عام 2001 20 اختار
باستمرار الاعتماد على روسيا لاحتواء نفود
ايران في سوريا واعتبر ان القوات الروسيه
المنخرطه بشكل مباشره في سوريا منذ ايلي
ايلول 2015 كانت الوحيده القادره على كبح
جماح نشاط الحرس الثوري الايراني
والمليشيات التابعه له ومن بينها حزب الله
وسمح ذلك بتطوير علاقه شخصيه بين نتنياهو
وبوتن وهو مكرسته دعوته الى ساحه الحمراء
في عام 2018 لحضور العرض العسكري لاحياء
ذكرا انتصار عام
1945 وهو ايضا ما يساهم في التنسيق
العسكري بينهما في سوريا
كما اغلق الفخر الروسيه على اسرائيل ما
يبرر رفضها تسليم اي معدات عسكريه الى
اوكرانيا للحفاظ على علاقتها بالموسكو ومن
سوريا ايضا يمكن لبتا ان يمارس ضغطا فعالا
للغايه ضد نظيره التركيه ويكفي ان تشم
موسكو هجوما على جيب ادلب الذي مازال خارج
سلطه بشار الاسد لتتسبب في النزوح ملايين
اللاجئين الى تركيا يفسر ذلك محدوديه
الدعم التركي لاوكرانيا رغم الكميه
المحدوده من طائرات برقدار التي زودت بها
انقره كيا كل ذلك يعني ان الشرق الاوسط
يبقى خزان الكرملين الاساسي سياسيا
وعسكريا وهذا البعد الشرق اوسطيه اضحى
معطى مهم عند تحليل ازمه العالم الحاليه
معنا في البعد الاخر وارحب به اهلا بك
معنا ساعه استفير
شكرا جزيلا نكون معكم
كما قدمت انه لا يمكن او لا يوجد شخص على
وجه الارض يمكن ان يتحدث عن ملف اوكرانيا
ونيته وروسيا من وجهه نظر امريكيه مثلك
انت في اكثر فتره حساسه في العلاقات بين
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق والولايات
المتحده كنت انت المسؤول الاول في الاداره
الامريكيه عن ملف اوكرانيا روسيا واوروسيا
وهذا يدفعني للسؤال الاول هل كنت تتوقع ان
نصل الى ما وصلنا اليه اليوم
عام 94
لان روسيا التزمت باحترامي سياده اوكرانيا
اراضيها والتزمت بعدم استخدام القوه ضد
اوكرانيا
همم بعد سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي كيف كانت
من وجهه نظرك الاتصالات وقتها بين
الادارتين الامريكيه والروسيه ما علاقه
رئيس الكاجوبيه ان ذاك الذي مر بها
في البيت الابيض
جدا
98 او 99
لم يكن عامل مؤثرا وفي منتصف الاول
الماضي
جيده جدا
طيب الان
عندنا تقريبا ربع قرن من حكم بوتن كيف
تقيم هذه الفتره ما الذي ساعه بوتن في وضع
بلاده على الطريقه التي يراها هو انها
الطريق الافضل
في روسيا واصبح اكثر التسلطن ولكنه يتخلى
عن السلطه عام 2008
في فتره الرئاسيه الثانيه التي بدات عام
وهذه الحرب الماساويه اليوكرانيا وكاراتيه
لروسيا روسيا كانت الدوله
خلال السنه هذه الحرب على اوكرانيا سوف
تسرع من انحدار روسيا وكيفما انتهت الحرب
عسكريا واقتصاديا وجيو سياسيين
تعتبر انه عام 2013
هو السنه المفصليه التي تقرر فيها غاز
اوكرانيا بسبب اكتمال جاهزيتها للانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي وربما النيته له تفصل
لنا في هذا الموضوع هل يمكن ان يكون هذا
هو سبب كل التعقيدات الموجوده حاليا
روسيا كانت همم
في عام 2010 البرلمان قال له اوكراني مر
الراقانونا مفاده ان اوكرانيا سيكون لديه
وضعيه خارجه عن الكتله وفي عام 2013 ورئيس
سنه كوفيتش الاوكراني لم يرغب الانضمام
الى الناتج ولم يكن هنالك اي يدفع من
السكان الاوكرانيين
هو الاخترابي من الاتحاد
حددت همم روسيا بعقوبات اقتصاديه
على اوكرانيا قبل 10 ايام الرئيس يعني
اتفاق مع الاتحاد الرو
هو هذا الذي تسبب بكل ما حصل بعد ذلك في
لقاء سابق كنت اجريت مع المفكر نعم شمسكي
في هذا البرنامج قال بانه همم اداره بيل
كلينتون تحديدا انقلبت على اتفاق جنتل من
بين برج الاب وبروسيالتن يقضي هذا الاتفاق
انا ذاك بعدم توسع الناتو ما مدى دقه هذا
الكلام
انا عملته على المكتب السوفيتي في عام 90
وفي ذلك الوقت
اي انه لن يكون هنالك اي ناقل اللي جنود
في شرقي المانيا اتفاق مع اعاده توحيد
المانيا في عام 90 فني لقوات لن تغادر
المانيا لغايه عام 94 بالكامل انا لم اكون
افكر في اي سنه مثلها وجمهوريه تشيكن
يوضح لان الشخص اخر قال له رايته
هذا السؤال وقال انه في المفاوضات مع
الغرب حول التوحيد المانيا
انه لم يكن هنالك نقاش حول التزاماتنا
وعدم توسيعه يعني
غير دقيقه ولم يعكسها السجلات تاريخيه
فعلا بالعوده الى اوكرانيا انه اوكرانيا
غير محايده اوكرانيا غربيه تشكل تهديد
وجودي لروسيا
السؤال هو لماذا قد يفكر الشخص بذلك لماذا
تكون الاوكرانيا قريب من الغرب تحديدا
روسيا مره اخرى عام 2013 كانت هنالك
اوكرانيا محايده هو الاستطلاعات الرايه
العامل اثنا عشر 2013
ثانك يو مره اخرى لا اعتقد بان اوكرانيا
التي لديها اواصر بالغابه تمثل تهديدا
لروسيا وعلينا ان نتذكر انه قبل بدء الحرب
في عام 20 22 الجيش الروسي ما خصه الافراد
النشيطين كان اربعه اضعافا حجمه الجيش
الاوكراني وروسيا انطقت بين 10 الى 15 ضعف
سنويا
4,500
سلاحف السفر
الماضي
ولكن فكره الجغرافيا بتفرض نفسها هنا ان
تكون في خاطره همم روسيا همم دوله غربيه
تماما اذا كان الميول الغربيه
هذه هي المشكله الكثيره في اوروبا وامريكا
التي واجهناها مع روسيا وهي ان روسيا تسعى
لطرد ايرادتها
على الفضاء السوفيتي الاسبق والتسعه اللي
يعني كلها صوت المهمه
المتحده
تحدي
عليها روسيا حتى مع اوكرانيا لقبولته
ولكنني اعتقد ان ستكون كارتيه لروسيا ايضا
تبقى معنا سنذهب الى فاصل قصير ونعود بعده
لمتابعه هذه الحلقه
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد واكرر الترحيب
بالسفير ستيف بايفر المتحدث باسم
الذي شغل منصب سفيرا لاكثر من ربعي قارن
في عده
دول وعواصم وان تكون سفير في موسكو ولندن
يعني تقريبا ابرز ثلاث عواصم تصنع الحدث
في الملف الاوكراني الخطير الان بتداعياته
على العالم كيف كيف تشرح لي الموقف
البريطاني الذي يبدو انه راس حربه في ال-
ال- سحر بعض الدروس او في العداء
للروسيكل
السفارات في مصر والله لكن
براءه البريطاني
تقريبا
نتذكر ان هناك
2006 و عام 2018
دوري دوري
يكون في نهايه عام 20 21 من ان روسيا كانت
تستعد
لسان غزوه عسكري وعمليه عسكريه كبيره
انتقل من الحديث عن الامن الاوروبي بدون
روسيا الى الامن الاوروبي ضد روسيا ما
رايك
حاول سيده تنسى الزواج
الماضي عده اتفاقات الاتفاق الامني في
اوروبا والمعاهده حاضرين الصواريخ المتوسط
المدافئه اوروبا
والمعاهده القوات المسلحه العديد من
الاتفاقات
في عام 2008
[موسيقى]
ستقيد الصواريخ اوروبا واجراء منها اشياء
ستحقق اسامينا حقيقيا للامن الاوروبيه
ولكن الرؤساء قالوا كلا ما لم يكن مستعدين
الموافقه على اجزاء اخرى من اتفاقا مثلا
عدم توسيعين يتودع مستعده لتعهدي بذلك
وطلب من السياحه
بالقوات العسكريه
انضمت الى انها بعد عام 97
تهديدا عسكريا
وانا دول انا الان تزوده
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن استقلالها وفي مرحله
ربما نستطيع ان نعود الى موسكو حول الامن
مع روسيا ولكن سيطاب ذلك اولا من ان توافق
العدد استخدام القوه العسكريه لتغيير رسمي
الحدود ويجبرك لديها قبوله لعلاقات مسالمه
مع الدول الجوار هذا يعني بانه ما ذكره
المتحدث باسمك الكرام لان اللي اعتبر قبل
الايام انه على اوكرانيا قبل كل شيء ان
تقر بان لوغانس
كودونسيا وخيرسون مناطق تنتمي الى روسيا
هذا الموضوع غير قابل للنقاش غير قابل ان
يكون على طاوله مفاوضات بين
الطرفين‬».\
روسيه حينها لم تسيطر على كره الكلمه
كامله فيها ثاني من اكتوبر
قال ما الذي اا حاولت روسيا ان تضمه ولم
يستطع ان يحدد ذلك
واروسيا تحاول تضم اراضي من اوكرانيات
الثلاثين من سبتمبر على الرغم من ان الجيش
الروسي كان يخسر المعركه والحربه اوكرانيا
بدا من نهايتها اغسطس الاشهر الاخيره
الاربعه من 22 السنه الاوكرانيون عمليات
هجوم مراد
المناطق التابعه لاوكرانيا
يكفي الى الان نشهد مثلا اي جهود حقيقيه
من قبل موسكو اي مقترحات جديا من قبل
موسكو لوجود نهايه لهذه الحرب
كل ما ذكرته في مكاسب روسيه على الارض شهر
بعد شهر اليس يعني حتى لو في بعض المناطق
لم تستطع تحقيق ما ارادته فيها ليس من شان
هذا ان يمهد الطريق لمفاوضات من نوع ما او
ربما لاحقا فرض امر واقع يجبر زلانسكي على
تفاوض
اتنينكم
العسكريه
التي اسيطر عليها جيش الروسي بعد 24 من
فبراير 20 220
فااوكرانيا لا نحرت اكثر من نسبه الكلمه
نعطها
ولذلك هو في هذه المرحله من الزمن
امكانيه جيده من الالكترونيه
طبيعيه ستختفي وشاهدوا في منطقه
مقابل الجماعيه وغرفه تعذيب والاختطاف
للاطفال الاوكرانيون وعددهم الى روسيا
فاتوقعوا من عند الاوكرانيين سوف يستمرون
بالقتال همم من اجل مقاومه هذا الغزوه
روسي
وتستحق دعم العالم
روسيا ترى هزيمتها في هذه الحرب هو هزيمه
من قبل الغرب اليها لذلك حتى النهايه في
في القتال ما رايك
لا تقول انها تحارب في اوكرانيا تقول
تحارب الدول الغربيه من خلال اوكرانيا
الشخص ان يقول
الغرب
اوكرانيا
الغربي
[موسيقى]
ولكن استخدامه هذه ضاربي الاهداف في
الاراضي الروسيه فالفكره ان هذه الحرب
وجوديه بالنسبه لروسيا لا اعتقد بانها
اسيا وحقيقيه ما قد يكون وجوديا هو انه
اذا ما خسرت روسيا هذه الحرب فمن الصعب ان
يبقى توتا
روسيه ستبقى كيفما انتهت هذه الحرب
شكرا
على المشاركه معنا في هذه الحلقه من البعد
الاخر شكرا جزيلا
والى هنا مشاهدينا الكرام انتهت حلقه
اليوم من البعد الاخر يمكنكم دائما
متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر وفيسبوك يوتيوب كما يمكنكم الاستماع
الى حلقاتنا على العربيه
[موسيقى]